the thermite reaction which is the
reaction of aluminium and iron oxide is
used to make iron and because aluminium
has much stronger bonds to oxygen than
iron that the reaction produces an
enormous amount of heat and you can use
this for welding pieces of metals
together so this is a thermite mixture
it's a mixture of iron oxides and
aluminium powder and we're gonna do some
redox chemistry and we're going to
generate some molten iron which will
hopefully stream from the bottom of the
of the flower pot so here you can see
the black particles of the iron oxide
and the silver particles of the
aluminium powder so we get some heat on
this we start an instantaneous redox
reaction so the aluminium and the iron
oxide swap oxygens so the aluminium will
become oxidized the iron will become
reduced hopefully will generate a lot of
molten iron which should come from the
bottom of the test tube of the flower
pod right now there's a story about
students in Berkeley that some students
decided or group of students decided to
do a practical joke on the tram which of
the sort that has one door when you go
in and another one where you go out so a
big group of students chewed onto the
tram and got into the front and there
were enough of them so that they could
actually come out at the end at the
other door and form a loop so they were
just going round and round and round so
the tram couldn't leave because they
were just more and more people getting
on
good rather tight and while they were
doing this other students went down
under the tram and set off to thermite
reactions and welded the wheels metal
wheels of the tram to the steel rail so
that when the tram tried to leave when
the students eventually stopped going
round and round it was firmly welded to
the tracks and couldn't move at all
don't look down on that
so instantly the thermite reaction
starts and you can see that it's so hot
it's bird a hole through the bottom of
that terracotta flowerpot but if we go
in close no Brady you can see all that
really quite nice molten iron now that's
so hot that the iron itself is melted
and it's formed it's really quite big
goo in the bottom on the on the sand do
you encourage these sort of practical
jokes no no no no no our students are
far more responsible so as soon as the
firework or the sparkler hit the top of
the thermite reaction in the top of here
it started off the instantaneous redox
reaction so this was where the metals
were fighting for the oxygen the
aluminium won that battle and the
aluminium came out of this reaction as
aluminium oxide the iron was reduced and
we can see that now in the bottom which
is really hot so I'm not going to get
too close but you can see all of this
really really hot iron so the iron was
molten it dribbled out through the
bottom of the flower pot and it's now
cooling well it it smashed its way in
the flower pot well you can say that
iron is in my blood it's in your blood
as well it's iron that gives hemoglobin
the red pigment in your blood it's red
color so the reaction we saw was about
five minutes ago and and the iron that
was generated is still glowing red hot
and you can see it's fused itself to the
bottom half of it of the flower pot
which which it broke in its tumultuous
step forward it is an absolutely
essential molecule to element to life
except for crabs which use copper but
you'll have to hear about that later so
iron ions are really really abundant
metal which is used as lots of lots of
structural material so you can see lots
of pieces of iron around some of the
racking and even facts some of these
pieces of equipment have got high iron
content they've got other elements mixed
with them to form alloys like stainless
steel I have an extremely long-standing
interested in its chemistry and
particular I made one compound of iron
so called and tetra carbonyl which had
four groups around it and everybody had
expected
that it would have a shape like one of
these shaped with tetrahedron like that
whereas in fact it turned out that it
had a much more irregular shape the four
groups were arranged like this and so
ever since this every time might hear
the word iron and get quite excited so
this is iron wire okay and you can see
this is a very small wire it's point two
of a millimeter in diameter and you can
see the the shiny material underneath is
iron that hasn't undergone oxidation so
this is where it's been protected from
the oxygen in the air now if we look at
the iron at the top we can see this
looks really familiar especially because
it looks like the rust that we might
find on the bottom side of some of our
cars here's some iron oxide on top of
the iron the very first chemical
experiment I did with chemical reaction
was with iron and I think the same is
true for many generations of school
children i heated that iron and sulfur
together and made iron sulphide sort of
blackish solid but then we put acid on
it and got a terrible smell of bad eggs
and this was my introduction to
chemistry and I really loved it